all right it's easy to become numb to
media bias these days so the ingram
angle is keeping track of the worst
offenders of the week now joining me is
jeff
lord former cnn commentator and
contributing editor of the american
spectator
and adam gullett uh a president of
accuracy and media
panel all right first up msnbc's claire
mccaskill
doesn't want to watch fireworks on the
4th of july instead
she's got this great new deranged
tradition we're going to start a new
family tradition in my family on the 4th
of july
and every 4th of july going forward
we're going to watch that video
that the new york times put together of
january 6.
jeff what a twisted way to celebrate our
nation's independence
uh congressman i can only imagine if
this was 1775
she would have been supporting the
british because of course she would have
been totally opposed to the boston tea
party
and she would have been opposed to the
battle of bunker hill
and on and on it would have gone i mean
there's a whole list of video i mean i
looked today
there's a whole list of videos and
movies about all of those
then maybe claire mccaskill should sit
down and uh
and take a look at him i mean it this is
just
unbelievable and maybe even she might
want to sit down and watch an interview
that lawrence jones of fox news did
with the father of a seven-year-old girl
who was shot to death in chicago
in 2020 and see just what's going wrong
in a democratic-run city maybe watch
that video yeah lawrence jones does a
fabulous job adam what was your take on
what claire mccaskill wants to do
well i'll tell you what i'm not going to
the july 4th barbecue at the mcclaskell
household what a bummer that place is
conservatives libertarians moderates we
are somber on memorial day we're somber
on 9 11.
how the heck is this lady somber on
independence day
the declaration of independence our
freedom was the greatest advancement of
human liberty in the history of
civilization
and it puts a frown on her face my gosh
yeah all right let's let's go to the
next one here's political hack
matthew dowd ginning up domestic
insurrection
fears watch this there's 300 million
guns
in america uh that we have spread across
the country
and that really concerns me in the
immediate
i'm i'm concerned that january 6 was
just a preliminary event
for worse things that could happen and
more loss of life in the course of this
and it's a
very very scary thing
all right adam this just shows how
deeply paranoid paranoid dowd and the
rest of the media elite are what's your
take
well since when were progressives
against mass
violence i recall last summer nearly
every city in the country was getting
burned down
and these guys were literally and
metaphorically fanning the flames to the
best of their ability
they even had celebrities who were
tweeting and bragging
about paying the bail money for the
rioters thankfully we had thousands of
accuracy and media activists
who basically tattletailed to their
parents on them we
called their managers agents and
publicists and sent tens of thousands of
emails and told them to
cut it out and they did but i never can
take it seriously whenever these people
claim
to be against violence especially after
what we saw last year
you know jason yeah i know please
in terms of what jeff's saying there was
a princeton study
there were uh there was violence in 48
out of the 50 largest cities in the
united states in 2020
the garden guardian reported that there
were at least 11 americans who were
killed while participating in these
riots
uh and there were another 14 and died
who died
in length related incidents so where is
the concern well
yeah about that the total pass yeah
and and you had kamala harris just last
year
working to bail these people out put
them back on the street as quickly as
possible
all right cnn's jeffrey toobin had the
most
ironic comment of the week wait till you
see this
talking about trump among other things
was the great reputation destroyer you
know
virtually everyone who served in his
administration
came away with a diminished uh
reputation
he's the expert on diminished
reputations i buy that
but jeff should he really be talking
about this on national
uh no uh yeah i know you know jeff
toobin's a former colleague
um how do i say he made a big mistake
big time and bigger than big time on
television i just can't really say
it but the main point here is
that donald trump uh served honorably as
president of the united states
the people who work for him and i know
lots and lots and lots of them
are proud of him and will always be
proud of him and
uh a big mistake big mistake here
particularly
not not sad adam i want to get your
very quick take on that sure i want
jeffrey tubing giving me pr advice
about as quickly as i want hunter biden
as a life coach
i guess you'll learn more from a defeat
than a victory so in that regard he must
know it all
uh all right we better just leave it
there gentlemen thank
you